mais à partir de la boue ce que nous
pouvons aéroportée ou envoyer des
gouttelettes à la personne qui est en
face de nous nous donc l'idéal c'est le
masque chirurgical 90% des cas cités
malheureusement il n'y en a pas pour
tout le monde donc il y aura à partir de
maintenant chez les pharmaciens et je
voudrais saluer le rôle des pharmaciens
et je trouve dommage que les pharmaciens
n'est pas jouer un rôle plus important
jusqu'à maintenant mais aussi chez les
buralistes ou ailleurs des grandes
surfaces des masques alternatif faits de
coton et le cocteau empêche cette c'est
de transmission en fond de vous vers la
personne qui est en face
il faut savoir que dans les transports
en commun moi personnellement je suis
pour que le match soit obligatoire mais
à condition que tout le monde porte est
donc là vous arrivez à une efficacité
prêter que -90% d'autant plus que la
semaine dernière on a appris que le
virus pouvait être aéroportée il n'y a
pas que les gouttelettes alors edouard
philippe doit présenter son plan de
déconfinement demain vous êtes médecin
vous avez été évidemment ministre vous
savez donc la difficulté de l'arbitrage
entre la décision politique est celle du
domaine médical qu'attendez-vous de main
du premier ministre du gouvernement en
fait la difficulté pour les autorités
nationales
quelles qu'elles soient dans le monde
c'est d'une part d'éviter le rebond
épidémique et d'autre part éviter
l'effondrement économique
donc ce que je crois c'est que le mot
conscience doit être la clé on parle des
écoles non par les transports en commun
on parle de de beaucoup de choses au
fond pour que le la vie recommence comme
avant
il ya une seule condition majeure c'est
donner confiance
donc il ya eu suffisamment d'erreurs qui
ont été faites jusqu'à maintenant pour
qu'on présente maintenant une stratégie
globale et surtout détaillé concrètes
comme celle dont je viens de parler par
exemple pour aller chercher les cas
positifs et leurs contacts il moins
jeunes ont une confiance s'il n'y a pas
la confiance salutaire
il n'y aura pas de reprise économique
sérieuse
donc oui j'attends demain qu'il y ait un
certain degré de détail de choses
concrètes de la part du premier ministre
alors l'un des points d'achoppement ont
parlé de cette difficulté d'arbitrage
entre le politique et le médical cette
illustration avec l'école le retour à
l'école qui fait beaucoup parler le
conseil scientifique aurait clairement
recommandé le retour à l'école en
septembre emmanuel macron arbitré
autrement sans doute aussi pour des
raisons économiques un d'inégalités
évidemment mais aussi économiques
on est dans la décision politique qui
peut être regrettable pour le médecin
qu'en pensez vous alors moi à titre
personnel c'est vrai que j'aurais été en
charge du pays
j'aurais fait une rentrée scolaire en
fait mais nous sommes dans une période
d'union nationale donc je vais parler de
la rentrée scolaire
je crois qu'elle peut être faits donnant
plus que on sait que les enfants
représentent moins de un pour cent des
hospitalisations en france donc non pas
nos risques et les enfants au fond et
n'offrent pas et transmettent peu le
virus al'inverse de la crypte où ils
transmettent beaucoup le que de laquelle
elle transperce
ils transmettent très peu le virus du
coronavirus alors par contre il faut
qu'il y ait des tests qu'ils soient
faits pour les enseignants pour les
employés municipaux départementaux
régionaux en fonction des écoles
primaires des écoles des collèges et des
lycées mais que aussi les papas et les
mamans qui attendent les enfants
puissent être testés
si jamais il y avait un enfant camélat
fier qu'on puisse y prendre la
température des enfants et s'il ya un
enfant qui a particulièrement la fièvre
ou à l'air mal à nous tous il faut
évidemment immédiatement testé toute la
classe voire l'école enfin il faut
qu'ils distanciation social dans et
compris lorsqu'ils des jeunes et y
compris dans les classes avec dged et 2
- coliques et bien évidemment regardé de
très près testez de très près l'ensemble
des personnes qui sont autour des
enfants
une dernière question philippe
douste-blazy une cargaison chloroquine à
destination de l'armée était filmé et
diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux elle a
suscité de nombreuses réactions
le ministère a expliqué que aulas il se
préparer en cas d' efficacité avérée du
traitement contre le kobe 19 vous
connaissez bien le sujet puisque vous
siégez ali us méditerranée il ya une
beaucoup de suspicion sur ce médicament
mais l'état on achète au cas où ce c'est
surprenant selon vous bon c'est une
discussion qui a eu lieu ce que l'on
sait aujourd'hui c'est que le taux de
mortalité dans les bouches du rhône où
il y a cette stratégie du professeur
round à la fois de tester très largement
pour avoir les cas très gosse et les
traités avec des antiviraux abouti à une
mortalité qui est beaucoup plus basse
qu'en france de la même manière au maroc
en algérie au sénégal où on traite avec
ce protocole il y à une mortalité qui
est pratiquement identique est très
basse et donc il y à là progressivement
c'est vrai une absence de preuves par
des essais cliniques que l'eau n'a en
général en temps de paix mais là nous
sommes dans l'urgence est donc voilà on
a les résultats de mortalité
malheureusement les tests qui ont été
faits des essais cliniques qui ont été
faits en france les deux roues de cycle
euros qu'ils ne pourront pas être
parlant puisqu'on a donné en france et
d'autres cycles rouquine aux personnes
qui ressemble qui ont des cas sévères
c'est à dire les cas où hydroxyque
l'euro qui n'est pas efficace ne pourra
pas encore une fois dé définir si le
cyclone qui n'aura été efficace en tout
cas des taux de mortalité sont entrées
par an merci beaucoup philippe
douste-blazy professeur de médecine
ancien ministre de la santé merci à vous
et la france qui déplore aujourd'hui
plus de 23000 décès liés au corps d'un
virus selon un nouveau bilan donné par
la direction générale de la santé la
hausse de ces dernières 24 heures et de
4 137 morts dont 295 dans les hôpitaux 1
depuis le début de l'épidémie 45 mille
cinq cent treize personnes sont rentrées
à domi
sans compter les dizaines de milliers de
personnes guéries en ville cette semaine
de confinement qui engendre évidemment
des tensions dans les quartiers
sensibles notamment le préfet de police
de paris et demande la suspension de
deux fonctionnaires de polices après la
diffusion d'une vidéo où on les entend
tenir des propos clairement raciste des
images sur lesquelles on voit notamment
un homme interpellé par la police sur
l'île saint denis l'homme aurait sauté
dans la seine pour échapper à un
contrôle de police
alors qui les conduit vers les camions
des forces de l'ordre l'un des
fonctionnaires de police aurait tenu des
propos donc raciste à l'encontre de
l'individu l'igpn a été saisie de
l'enquêté
les images que vous allez voir sont des
extraits de vidéos
enlever
oublie la jirs
c'est pas nager sous les poteaux
m
les ministres de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a réagi sur twitter après la
diffusion de cette vidéo sur les réseaux
sociaux il indiqué que l'igpn avait été
saisi une vidéo montrant une
intervention de police dans le secteur
de l'île saint denis suscitent une
indignation légitime
toute la lumière sera faite l'igpn est
saisi le racisme n'a pas sa place dans
la police républicaine et autres
illustrations de tension deux motards de
la police cette fois ont été
hospitalisés après avoir été percutés ce
soit par une voiture à colombes
d'individus qui les auraient ciblé
volontairement a également percuté une
voiture des forces de l'ordre les agents
de police effectué des contrôles
routiers relatif au confinement
lorsqu'ils ont été pris pour cible le
suspect un jeune homme de 29 ans a été
placé en garde à vue les services
antiterroristes sont attendus sur place
et pour en parler nous sommes avec eric
coquerel député la france insoumise
première circonscription de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir eric coquerel
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france une
question un petit peu global
effectivement ces deux incidents qu on
ne compare pas qu'on ne met pas sur le
même pied d'égalité évidemment on
parlera des deux vous craignez vraiment
une escalade de ces tensions les
tensions liées pour vous confinement
notamment dans les quartiers difficiles
vous savez il escalade des tensions il
faudrait pour ça que au parc d'un niveau
il n'y a pas de tensions elles
n'existent toujours les tensions elles
sont souvent passés sous silence
d'abord parce qu'on n'a pas toujours les
vidéos pour en témoigner
mais malheureusement les tensions entre
une certaine partie de la police et les
quartiers populaires les jeunes souvent
les gènes il faut le dire
sion d'origine en tout cas il convient
par action qui qui j'allais dire
chi chi dont on peut parler à leur
encontre pardon excusez moi de réactions
racistes c'est ça c'est ça fait
longtemps que dans les quartiers
populaires ça ça glisse alors c'est vrai
quand le confinement ça al'air
d'augmenter considérablement
est ce que c'est parce que le
confinement est un prétexte de plus
court
j'allais lire des vexations des actes
des déclarations violentes des actes
violents
des propos racistes peut-être mais en
tout cas on voit il suffit de regarder
les réseaux sociaux les plaintes qui
sont déposées 1
il ya au moins une quarantaine comme ça
d'action un véritablement problématique
qui sont déroulés du début du coq nom de
la part de la police
alors effectivement le ministre de
l'intérieur clairement qui prend parti
qui évoque voilà qu'ils se condamnent le
racisme dans la police pour vous je vous
pose la question clairement ça sera
d'ailleurs l'objet d'un débat dans
quelques minutes
y at il un problème de racisme dans la
police française il ya des rats fille
dans la plus française qui a fait sur et
le problème qui se pose c'est que depuis
quelques années il n'y a pas assez de
réaction de l'ordre de 2 de la
hiérarchie il ya même une loi du silence
pour aller dit il arrive parfois que par
exemple et quelques policiers n'étaient
pas du tout généralise pas mais qui se
permettent ce genre de propos et les
autres se taisent
donc c'est là où je dis qu'à une espèce
de loi de l'omerta et qui donne à ton
qui donne quelque chose dont on peut on
peut dire malheureusement c'est un côté
un peu plus ce système
voilà ça reste la nav yeux la violence
de certains policiers
à partir du moment où le corps du loup
la police se tait ou appartiendront la
hiérarchie n'était pas assez de choses
et bien malheureusement ces deux qui
donnent le là et ça fait ça fait trop
longtemps que ça dure
et là ça ça explose alors bon là
heureusement il ya une vidéo
donc là on pouvait pas faire autre chose
berne on pouvait pas faire autre chose 2
alertée ligier de police
bon il va pas non plus une pub des
peines pénales qui vont avoir lieu donc
j'espère qu'on va sanctionner durement
ceux qui ont tenu ces propos racistes
mais on va aussi se poser la question
pourquoi les autres disent rien pourquoi
les commissaires sur le terrain ne dit
rien c'est ça qui est problématique
moi je pense qu'il faut aborder ce
problème de fond c'est un pôle de
formation qui est un problème de moyens
aussi parce que je les policiers s'est
pas non plus facile à ses excuses en
rien une fois ci mais des actes violents
mais il est possible qu'il y ait des
moyens humains matériels ou bien faire
leur travail
on pas faire dans des conditions qu'ils
sont des conditions aussi dures proulx
et à partir de là il faut rien laisser
passer voilà la police républicaine ne
peut pas être une police dans lequel des
acteurs ou des contenus violents se
fasse malheureusement aussi facilement
c'est pas possible
en tout cas le préfet de police de paris
demandent ce soir la suspension des deux
policiers veut pas suffisant on imagine
pour vous tous que cela il faut que ça
aille dans le pénal et bien évidemment
faillite au pied des sanctions
administratives et de sanctions
judiciaires
mais encore une fois je vois pas bien ce
soit là qui cache la forêt que qui avait
pas eu la vidéo de nos voisins peut-être
qu'on ne saurait pas que des propos
comme ça ont été tenus et 15 un homme on
ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé après un
long temps des couches sur des bruits on
se lasse pilier palcy mais encore une
fois c'est c'est malheureusement trop
fréquent et caen est souvent la réaction
au conflit du gouvernement c'est de dire
ah ils sont par toute la vidéo je
trouvais le compte le contexte
non il ya des problèmes objectif il ya
trop longtemps qu'on est obligé par
rapport à telle ou telle bavure
policière 29 voir des fois qu'ils
peuvent entraîner la mort de certains de
dire nous réclamons la vérité pour ceux
des plus possible donc il faut il faut
aborder ce point de vue voilà et toi
problème abordé ce problème de fond on
doit avoir un gouvernement qui ne laisse
rien passer de ce côté de ce point de
vue là et s'ils ne se sert pas non plus
de la police à certains moments pour
maintenir à certain ordre social comme
une mauvaise avec les jaunes les
mouvements syndicaux et comme ils le
font depuis trop longtemps dans les
quartiers voilà la police des fois
souvent s'y est aussi cuisine au service
d'une politique socialement répressive
par rapport au quartier et ça aussi
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut aborder
tri eric coquerel une illustration une
autre illustration on en parle est un de
ces violences cette fois ci c'est la
police qui est victime de motards de la
police hospitalisés après avoir été
percutés par une voiture à colombes
apparemment l'individu aurait les aurait
ciblé volontairement quelle est votre
réaction
je condamne absolument bien évidemment
j'ai lu ça sur les twittos m'a fait
reculer un seul quatre commissaires sur
cette affaire c'est pas parce que on ne
doit rien laisser passer à nos policiers
raciste on ne doit rien laisser passer à
des actes violents
si tu êtes totalement disproportionnée
que par ailleurs on doit laisser passer
le fait que des policiers soient pris
pour cible voilà je veux évidemment
c'est condamnable je vais pas pour moi
c'est est évident tout comme d'ailleurs
je le dis moi je suis pour une police
républicaine et qu'ils aient les moyens
humains matériels de bien faire son
métier et qui ne soit pas et ça ça aussi
c'est une manière à un moment donné de
2,2 de le respecter
merci eric au fait d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france et des
policiers qui tiennent donc des propos
ouvertement racistes la vidéo qui a
suscité l'indignation sur les réseaux
sociaux le ministre de l'intérieur a
réagi le racisme n'a pas sa place dans
la police et publics n alors pour
reprendre les mots de christophe
castaner est il un problème de racisme
dans la police le confinement exacerber
les tensions c'est l'objet de notre face
à face
[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes nous avec
nabil boudi avocat à ses côtés on dirait
que par skype également christophe
crépin porte parole du collectif france
police policiers en colère bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous je
repose la question que je me posais eric
coquerel et que soulève le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe crépin y at il
selon vous un problème de racisme dans
la police aujourd'hui en france je peux
pas vous laisser dire qu'il ya à prendre
leur ainsi selon la police la caisse qui
on va redonner moi je ne ferme rien je
me pose la question
alors je vais vous répondre le
clairement madame non il n'y a pas de
problème du racisme
il y a eu un comportement qui a été
relevé par l'inspection générale qui va
mener une enquête aussi bien
administratives que judiciaire que
monsieur coquerel qui connaît très bien
les procédures se satisfait de cette
chose
les fonctionnaires qui n'ont rien à
faire chez nous sont systématiquement
éconduit mais dans la police nationale
il n'y a pas de problème de racisme
déjà par son recrutement et par son mode
de fonctionnement
c'est à dire avant de les laisser
reprendre la ville body c'est-à-dire
mode de fonctionnement ça veut dire quoi
nous sommes en pole ici une police
républicaine au service de toutes les
personnes quelles que soient leurs leur
idéologie quelle que soit leur situation
sociale
et quelles que soient leurs ethnies en
fait madame honneur au service de
l'ensemble de la population française et
nabil body est ce que la police est
raciste la réponse est non est ce que la
police des engrais n'est par des
comportements racistes
la réponse est oui est-ce que les
comportements racistes sont suffisamment
sanctionné
je ne le pense pas je te veux donner
deux éléments de réponse en main vie qui
sont intéressants vous savez quand vous
êtes noir ou arabe
vous avez dix fois plus de chances
d'être contrôlé par la police
c'est un comportement raciste pour moi
les autres d'identité qui se fonde sur
un critère racial sont des comportements
racistes de la part de la police
quand vous avez également cinq plus de
on est policier qui ont volé en 2017
pour le rassemblement national
ça ne me dit pas si la policière raciste
ou pas mais ça nous dit que certains
policiers ont fait le choix de voter
pour un parti qui selon moi n'est pas
républicain et vous avez utilisé ce
terme est là tout à l'heure le terme de
républicains si ce qu'on attend de la
part des policiers
un comportement républicain ce qui
signifie que l'interdiction formelle de
discrimination aujourd'hui la police
dont a selon moi se poser les bonnes
questions
nous traversons actuellement une crise
sanitaire sans précédent et on attendait
de la part des forces de l'ordre du
discernement de la pédagogie dans les
quartiers dits sensibles
on a vu tout au contraire c'est à dire
une aggravation et une explosion des
violences dans les quartiers c'est vrai
que ces images sont extrêmement choquant
on imagine que c'est assez contre
productif si j'ose dire quand on est
policier
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti quand
vous avez visionné cette vidéo qui a
fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
moi je suis des fonctions des policiers
bien évidemment cette vidéo ne met pas
en lumière des comportement honorable
c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'inspection générale qui a été saisie
fera exactement la part des choses
recadra bien ce qui ça puisse passer si
des fonctionnaires ont dérapé ces
fonctionnaires seront punis à la hauteur
du dérapage qu'ils ont commis mais je ne
peux pas laisser dire moreau tradicteur
que toute la police
même ceux qui ont voté pour le
rassemblement national sont racistes
parce que ce n'est pas vrai nous avons
des directives des directives sont
appliquées je peux vous dire que mes
collègues mes collègues qui sont dans
des zones sensibles et sec de faire du
mieux qu'ils peuvent
malgré le manque de moyens je reviens on
n'a pas de masque on n'a pas de gants on
n'a rien on essaye d'avoir une police
républicaine
c'est vrai que ces comportements ne sont
pas en voyant la vidéo sur pas honorable
pour mes collègues déjà ça c'est vrai
que je dois le reconnaître
mais ce n'est qu'une petite partie
d'individus qui se sont laissés aller
sur des railleries qui ne sont pas très
intelligent de leur part
je pense que ces gens là ils devront
répondre à l'inspection générale du côté
administratif et du côté également au
judiciaire
nabil boudi vous parliez voilà du des
taux de contrôle qui sont plus élevés
selon vous et vous dénoncez une forme de
racisme effectivement depuis le début du
confinement le taux de verbalisation en
seine-saint-denis frôlé le triple de la
moyenne nationale le département qui
totalisent 40 terme ils sont trois
contraventions pour 242 1259 contrôle
pour être précis pour vous c'est parce
qu'on contrôle plus ou parce que
peut-être il n'y a moins de respect tout
simplement du confinement on peut aussi
se poser la question sereinement
je suis passion entre le plus je sais
pas si à plus de violations de ce
confinement mais moi qui habite à paris
je peux vous dire que les rues sont
pleines en ce moment est d'ailleurs pas
plus tard que tout à l'heure de midi
pour me rendre au cabinet j'ai croisé un
tas demandant leur plu et j'ai vu très
peu contrôlées encore moins des
verbalisations
le problème de ces contrôles
ce n'est pas les contrats importants
tels que cette attestation qui sont
légitimes pour prévenir de la santé
publique depuis nos concitoyens ce sont
les comportements qui interviennent à la
suite de ces contrats vous savez moi je
représente une jeune fille qui habitait
au gravier qui a 19 ans elle est sortie
avec une attestation manuscrite de chez
elle elle a fait l'objet d'un contrôle à
la suite de gros de ce contrôle
sf états et par un agent des services de
l'or à bout par bout portant
au niveau de la poitrine vous avez un
individu pas plus tard que le week-end
dernier qui en descendant chez lui pour
première s'est fait interpeller et
violenté par une patrouille tout entière
de la police donc ce que je demande
aujourd'hui c'est que le comportement et
l'attitude des policiers qui exercent
dans les centres villes des grandes
agglomérations soit exactement le même
que celui qui est effectué dans les
quartiers populaires et pour ce faire
il va falloir arrêter d'urgence les
contrôles qui sont systématique à
l'égard d'une population désigné et je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure ses contrôles
sont illégaux dans la mesure où ces
contrôles sont discriminatoires
ils sont idéaux et je le répète il ya eu
tout un tas de communication aujourd'hui
la part de depuis ces derniers jours
depuis l'aggravation de ces violences
policières la part de certains syndicats
de police je dirais deux choses là
dessus heureusement dieu merci que ces
syndicats ne sont pas représentatifs de
la police française aujourd'hui qui fait
un travail remarquable il mon propos est
un peu tronqué par nouveau titeuf
je n'ai pas dit que tous les policiers
des racistes j'ai seulement précisé que
compte tenu de leurs fonctions la police
doit d'être irréprochable
c'est celle-ci qui est censé apporter la
sécurité aux français si aujourd'hui
vous avez des français disent sentent
menacés qui ont peur d'être contrôlé par
la police
c'est qu'il ya un problème qui est
structurelle et donc on n'a pas réglé ce
problème de fond la crainte sera
toujours présente et les accusations de
racisme père du roi envers la police est
triste après pas qu'est ce que vous
répondez à nabil abu dis je pense que
monsieur vous dit un excédent du cac qui
met un peu d'huile sur le feu là où il
ya tout et pas lieu de remettre
moi je vous dis que en effet dans le 93
il y à beaucoup plus de gens qui ne
respectent pas le gros le confinement
que dans paris c'est un façon visible
notre syndicat nous avions demandé que
l'argent des verbalisations soit il
reversés pour refaire une réforme
complète du système hospitalier
c'est une idée parce que c'est vrai que
ça va faire quand même beaucoup d'argent
à paris je vous assure monsieur que le
préfet de police
allumez les instructions pour contrôler
toutes les contrevenants qui soit ils
devoir et quelle que soit leur
nationalité je vous assure que c'est
vrai je vais pas débattre avec vous
parce que je pense que vous êtes dans
l'idée de dire que la police n'est pas
spécialement toujours exemptes de
reproches mais je vous assure qu'on
essaye de faire tout ce que nous pouvons
pour ne faire aucune preuve de
de racisme à l'égard des personnes de
suivre et à paris entre autant que dans
93 ou que dans le 94 ou que dans le 92
nabil boudi quand un policier on entend
des voix là sur les radios aujourd'hui
en france à la suite de cette affaire
des policiers des témoignages simple
d'hommes qui disait voilà c'est très
difficile parfois de travailler dans ces
quartiers il ya des bandes de jeunes
entre guillemets voilà je cite un
policier que j'écoutais chez nos
confrères de france info me roy la
guerre des bandes de cinq ans qu'ils
nous disent on ne respectera pas le
confinement de toute façon ne payera pas
demande est ce que c'est un fait que
vous contestez
et si vous ne le contestait pas ce que
vous n'estimez pas que c'est parfois
peut-être difficile pour un policier de
travailler dans ces conditions également
je compte les traces de cette allégation
selon laquelle dans certains quartiers
le confinement sur est moins bien
respectés d'ailleurs c'est absolument
faux rappelez-vous que personne et la
mémoire courte
au début du confinement sur les quais de
seine au trocadéro les attroupements
rappeler que dans le grand est aussi
dans certains lieux de culte ou la pire
était maintenue malgré le confinement
rappelez vous également dimanche
je vous rends sauvé hier parler ce qui
s'est produit dans le soutien lancement
je vais quasiment tous les jours dans le
16ème arrondissement et gère à ce jour
aujourd'hui l'impression que le
confinement n'a jamais eu lieu dans un
bar on en parle
pourquoi ça dégénère pas pourquoi n'y a
pas de violences policières
pourtant les personnes ne se confine pas
ne respecte pas l'état d'urgence and her
tout simplement parce que la police a
agi avec retenue et si cette retenue qui
doit prévaloir sur tous les contrôles
d'identité sans distinction et quand ces
contrôles d'identité seront réalisés de
la même manière sur tout un territoire
français on pourra considérer que tous
les policiers sont républicains
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
et je pense que la police a beaucoup à y
gagner aujourd'hui à se poser les bonnes
questions et notamment période de crise
tous les individus doivent être traités
à la même enseigne
je ne fais pas le procès de la police la
police d'un travail remarquable mais il
ya certains syndicats il ya certes un
policier aujourd'hui qui nous disent ce
qu'ils agissent avec très peu de décence
et qui que j'ai taxis noirs de pompier
pyromane christ a très bien le mot de la
fin je me suis pas du tout en accord
avec les propos que viennent de tenir
mon contradicteur de néanmoins il faut
que les français comprennent bien que la
police est à l'heure et la peau les
protéger et on continuera à avoir une
police républicaine si quelquefois il ya
des dérapages être sévèrement mais très
sévèrement punis et très souvent les
collègues qui ont commis ce genre de
dérapages ils sont exclus profession et
ils ont des sanctions judiciaires qui
seront très lourdes même plus lourd que
le commun des mortels voilà ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'ils sont nés là pour
protéger les citoyens quelles que soient
leurs ethnies quelle que soit l'heure de
leur classe sociale et on le protègera
merci beaucoup à tous les deux la ville
body christophe crépin d'avoir été avec
nous pour débattre merci et outre rendre
cette décision radicale pour limiter la
propagation du virus l'allemagne a
imposé dès aujourd'hui le port du masque
dans tous les transports en commun et
certains commerces
berlin fait figure de bon élève dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire avec moins
de 6000 décès mais le pays s'inquiète
d'une deuxième vague berlin qui a reçu
une livraison de 10 millions de masques
en provenance de la chine en présence de
la ministre allemande de la défense ma
vie n'est ni remords ni quoi que nous
décidions dans les semaines et les mois
à venir un nouvel assouplissement serait
une mesure prudente nous ne devons pas
compromettre ce que nous avons déjà
accompli avec succès ici en allemagne
cela dépend principalement de la
capacité à retracer les chaînes
d'infection mais le travail des
autorités sanitaires et aussi de
l'application smartphone
cela dépend fortement de notre
possession d'équipements de protection
appropriée de toutes sortes à ton âme l
obligation du port du masque une mesure
plutôt bien accueillie par la population
malgré certaines contraintes écoutez je
suis dans le domaine de la santé
et je pense qu'on aurait dû mettre ça en
place depuis longtemps pour nous
protéger les uns des autres
une fille a été touchée on sait depuis
longtemps qu'on peut au moins protéger
les autres avec le masque peut être même
soi même il est trop tard à mon avis on
aurait dû réagir beaucoup plus tôt
immédiatement mais cela ne fait pas de
mal de se promener avec un masque
ça tient chaud ça glisse on respire mal
mais oui si c'est pour éviter les
infections samedi au royaume uni l
épidémie a fait plus de 21000 décès dans
les seuls hôpitaux mais la courbe
commence à s'inverser selon boris
johnson le premier ministre britannique
romy ducobu 19 café ce matin sa première
apparition publique depuis sa guérison
il appelle les britanniques à rester
confinés et l'âme et medjahed sorti des
soins intensifs depuis une quinzaine de
jours
boris johnson est désormais totalement
remis de son infection kovy 19
le premier ministre britannique a donc
repris la main sur les affaires du
royaume uni et fait sa première
déclaration à la presse ce lundi que
boeing seul en lice ed rec les insultes
je veux m'adresser aux acteurs
économiques aux entrepreneurs à tout ce
dont notre économie dépend moins en vue
mais je comprends votre impatience
je sais que sans une impulsion un vrai
sens il n'y aura plus l'économie d'un
autre pays votre urgence c'est celle du
gouvernement
nous devons reconnaître le risque d'une
seconde vague le risque de perdre le
contrôle face à ce virus est nul ce ne
sera pas une nouvelle vague de morts
mais aussi un désastre économique
une visite dont seul un écumant m'excuse
rast
boris johnson fait face à une pression
grandissante pour dévoiler son plan de
déconfinement le leader conservateur de
55 ans doit également affronter les
critiques pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
un schéma se dessine ici nous avons été
lents à entrer film en lan sur les
dépistages lent à mettre en place des
équipements de protection mais
maintenant leur accès aux offres
d'équipements britannique
le premier secrétaire affirme qu'il ya
une capacité de 40 minutes est par jour
cela signifie qu'avant tierces à 48,16
aurait pu être effectuées mais mais que
seuls 18 mille ont été réalisés
critiques de l'opposition mais aussi
division en coulisses au sein même de
l'équipe au pouvoir selon la presse
britannique certains poids lourds
s'inquiètent des conséquences sociales
mais aussi sanitaire d'un confinement
trop strictes sur la longueur boris
johnson va donc devoir trancher avec une
équation délicate à résoudre comment
faire redémarrer l'économie
au royaume uni sans risquer un deuxième
pic de la pandémie et pour évoquer le
royaume uni nous sommes en direct de pin
up sport d'avec mycloud journaliste
indépendant c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir mes claques merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur france boris johnson
de retour et il est attendu selon vous
au tournant il est pile un an il est
attendu au tournant
il est assez malade il a été très malade
même du coffee 19
il est de retour aujourd'hui et il
n'était pas très réaliste de s'attendre
à ce qu'ils disent que le confinement
serait levé avant le 3 mai la date
indiquée pour le bilan thueux
confinement cependant il a bien dit
qu'il y aurait des discussions au cours
des prochaines journées sur l'avenir et
il est important de comprendre que le
coiffe humain ce n'est pas ce jeu
gagnant perdant
c'est dire que le confinement a
également causé des morts les gens ne
vont pas à l'hôpital pour des problèmes
qu'ils ont qui ne sont pas à lier un
cours un virus et que s'agir de cancers
de maladies cardiaques
'cela signifie que des ces personnes
vont mourir de sa cause donc ce n'est
pas son personnel
c'est pourquoi la décision de lever le
bon finement beaucoup de paramètres
car si on lève trop souvent et trop
fortement alors il pourrait y avoir un
renforcement du nombre confection
peut-être mais s'il ne fait rien et
qu'on continue de la sorte alors il y
aurait bien sûr des grands percussions
économique et ils eurent également des
morts lui confinement donc c'est très
très compliqué effectivement c'est une
voix qu'on n'a pas l'habitude en france
c'est vrai que
en france en général que ce soit les
hommes politiques ou les français sont
davantage vouloir pousser au confinement
rejoindre pour fouad le nombre de
parents qui souhaitent garder leurs
enfants à la maison au lieu de les
mettre à partir du 11 mai donc différent
au royaume uni où l'opposition et
notamment les milliers d'affaires en
passant par les rangs des partis
conservateurs font un petit peu de
pression sur le premier ministre
justement pour plus de souplesse
comment vous expliquez ça c'est tout
simplement dans la culture très libérale
britannique
effectivement c'est facilement car des
personnes à gauche l'iso les
capitalistes aux folles de déconfinement
ils veulent ramener les travailleurs au
travail il mettre en danger mais c'est
trop simpliste
les capitalistes sont partagés les
banques et les financiers considèrent
qu'un long confinement serait milliards
us de ses moyens sont prises au fil des
dettes c'est peut-être qu'ils ne
resteront pas le payer quand les bacs
récupéreront c'est sans surprise donc
pour ces personnes elles sont plutôt à
l'aise action finement mais voilà on a
perdu n'est clair je sais pas s'il va
revenir s'il va réapparaître neckar en
direct du royaume uni manifestement non
voulez vous on perd du petit problème de
liaison avec le royaume-uni veuillez
nous en excuser et est prêt à me voilà
une affaire qui revient voilà on y
arrive au cou alors en tout cas il ya un
homme qui a qui a changé son fusil
d'épaulé si j'ose dire c'est boris
johnson ans au début on s'en souvient on
le voyait assez désinvolte ans le
premier ministre vis-à-vis de cette
épidémie de corey may virus depuis il a
contracté la maladie ils sont nés remis
et il paraît beaucoup plus prudent
d'ailleurs il appelle les britanniques à
la patience 1 vous êtes étonnés par ce
changement d'attitude c'est parce qu'il
a été malade selon vous
je pense qu'effectivement la maladie va
pas changer car le 5 mars effectivement
il était à la télé et il minimisé le
virus il est ok même l'idée qu'on pourra
simplement le laisser se propager d'un
pays entier il a dit que continuerez à
serrer la main des gens le 5 mars à
justin et une semaine plus tard il était
bien plus sérieux dans une conférence de
presse il a été primé famille ferme un
plus haut à pratiquer beaucoup de
flamands ils vont perdre dans cette
recherche c'est une semaine plus tard et
puis ensuite c'est encore une semaine
après il a le confinement effectivement
la maladie l'a changée et j'entends avec
le cabinet britannique utilisées en même
temps quand les colons ben ali soit un
allègement du conflent
ils veulent que le gouvernement disait
voici ses confrères nous allons
commencer les entraînements et les
faucons disent non il est trop tôt nous
devons être prudents et continuer le
conflit dans la proche donc c'est une
lutte au sein du gouvernement en ce
moment c'est vraiment fascinant
il y à différentes opinions sans du la
population prêter leur confinement comme
angèle et y fait des victimes
il faut garder cela à l'esprit ces gens
qui ne seront plus local ni un gamin
donc l'impact économique et l'impact sur
notre société et sur notre santé avec
leur chômage par exemple qui est mauvais
pour la santé générale
gatti fin confiance se poursuivre et ce
après les votes
vraiment c'est nécessaire que ça me
chante lits et environ 300 à ce qui est
très près la terre parce qu'ils se
lassent et avant donc nous pensons que
23 mai il aura une décision importante
concernant la fin du confinement a
effectivement vous avez raison et claque
le royaume uni qui a enregistré
aujourd'hui 360 décès supplémentaires
en 24 heures soit le plus faible bilan
depuis mars merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous en direct pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir et après des
semaines un passé sous cloche l'europe
dans son ensemble à mort dont doucement
ce déconfinement tour d'horizon en
images
[Musique]
oh
les conséquences de l'épidémie au liban
à présent qui s'enfonce davantage dans
la crise depuis plusieurs jours les
libanais manifeste malgré les mesures de
confinement que partout dans le pays
l'armée a été déployée aujourd'hui pour
effectuer des manifestants qui
bloquaient une autoroute au nord de la
capitale et protestataires dénoncent la
dégradation de l'économie libanaise déjà
au plus mal avant la crise ducobu 19
le taux de pauvreté atteindrait
désormais les 45% selon certains
observateurs
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
tawil est économiste et président du
conseil économique et social du parti
kataeb bonsoir jean rainville et merci
d'être avec nous on a évidemment suivi
ici abondamment à l'actualité au liban
avant cette épidémie de corona virus à
la situation était déjà extrêmement
compliqué on imagine que l'épidémie a
clairement davantage encore aggravé la
situation
sûrement l'épidémie n'êtes pas lorsqu'on
est en train de voir aujourd'hui ce qui
est en train de se passer dans d'autres
pays parce qu'on est en train de voir
que les politiques budgétaires et
monétaires ou bien que d'autres pays ont
les moyens aujourd'hui d'être de
soutenir la population
malheureusement au liban avant même la
crise du coc vite 19 la situation au
liban était désastreuse on était dans
une grande crise économique l'état a
fait défaut de paiement n'a pas pu payer
ses dettes et a fait des shows il n'y a
plus de réserves en devises étrangères
dans le pays pour pouvoir soutenir la
monnaie qui était à 1500 livres qui
était fixé à 1500 livres aujourd'hui sur
le marché noir
la livre libanaise sur le dollar est à
4000 livres
donc voilà ça c'était la situation avant
aujourd'hui du fait du covic 19
l'économie c'est s'est ralentie en
grande partie beaucoup de de business en
train de
n'arrive plus à fonctionner son dg de
fermer leurs portes que ce soit le
secteur touristique et on sait très bien
combien le liban compte sur le secteur
touristique
outre des gens sont en train de perdre
leur travail
et malheureusement l'état n'a pas les
moyens de soutenir cette population est
de soutenir les gens les plus démunis
aujourd'hui clairement comment réagit le
gouvernement quelle est sa marge de
manoeuvre parce qu'évidemment il ya
toujours ce fameux curseur entre la
crise économique et la crise sanitaire
certainement les marges de manoeuvre
sont très limitées au niveau du
gouvernement d'un côté haut niveau ils
ont enfin les mesures qui ont été prises
ce sont principalement des mesures de
repousser les différents paiements que
ce soit les les taxes les impôts ou même
les factures d'électricité ou de
téléphone pendant quelques mois pendant
trois mois afin de donner une petite
période de grâce à la population au
niveau de la politique monétaire et les
taux d'intérêt il était déjà assez bas
mais la banque centrale a donné la
possibilité aux banques de prêter à 0 %
sur cinq ans afin de pouvoir aider
justement les compagnies à avoir un peu
de liquidités afin de continuer à payer
les salaires
mais ceci dit encore une fois les marges
de manoeuvre sont très limitées alors
que la crise elle et elle est beaucoup
plus grande qu'on ne croit effectivement
le fmi estime que le liban va vers une
récession de 12 % en 2020 on se demande
comment ce petit pays pourra sortir la
tête de l'eau est ce que vous restez
néanmoins optimiste ce qu'il faut savoir
ici c'est que c'est tout un modèle
économique qui s'est effondré au liban
avant il y avait un modèle économique
qui était non productifs c'est un modèle
économique qui était basé sur les flux
de dépôt qui rentrait dans l'économie
libanaise et qui finançait finalement le
système
système en place une fois que ces flux
se sont arrêtés une fois que les besoins
de les terres de l'état était beaucoup
plus grand que prévu
ce modèle s'est effondré la seule source
de devises étrangères qui rentrait dans
notre pays n'était que qu'à travers les
dépôts aujourd'hui on a une opportunité
en or de reconstruire notre économie on
a une opportunité de reconstruire un
modèle économique solide
un modèle économique productif et qui va
nous permettre de diversifier les
sources de devises étrangères qui rend
dans notre pays que ce soit à travers
une forte industrie libanaise et on
prenait désavantage compétitif à ce
niveau là qui va nous permettre de
booster nos exportations
que ce soit en créant un environnement
propice à l'investissement afin
d'attirer des investisseurs au liban
mais bien sûr d'autres services et le
secteur financier
mais tout ça a besoin d'abord de 1 d'une
stabilité politique est avant tout une
stabilité politique
après il va falloir entamer les réformes
qui sont nécessaires et qui sont
demandés depuis depuis beaucoup d'années
on se souvient très bien les promesses
qui ont été faites à paris durant la
conférence de s'être ces réformes là il
faut y aller il faut on n'a plus le
temps on a plus de temps à perdre
le premier ministre a dit hier lors
d'une d'une allocution télévisée
comme quoi le liban et on a perdu depuis
le début d'année jusqu'à maintenant 7
milliards de dollars merci jean tabi des
d'avoir été avec nous en direction est
et français dans quelques instants
rester avec nous reviendrons en france
avec le plan de déconfinement présenté
demain par edouard finit pas d'assemblée
et suivi d'un vote des députés
et puis nous partirons aux états unis
mais pour parler du
candidat démocrate à la maison blanche
joe biden accusé d'agression sexuelle ne
s'est pas encore exprimé son entourage
nie farouchement les faits
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant il faut
que peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays vieux sage
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
quelles conséquences du coronavirus sur
le sport d'un point de vue sanitaire
économique et sociale on en parle avec
vous invitez gervais martel ex président
du racing club de lens et christophe le
petit économiste du sport
on ne reprendra pas le sport
professionnel dans des conditions
normales il n'y a que le football
aujourd'hui qui restent encore accrocher
à cet espoir de pouvoir finir la saison
je veux me le tout aux poudres dans les
deux dans l'expective parmi les autres
sports professionnels français
tous ont pris la décision de ne pas
jouer la crise touche tout le monde
il conduit des rares outils aussi aux
frais de réfection tuer des branches
revenir à plus de mesure et faire en
sorte de construire en fait un business
sur un site plus durable économie lui
est peut-être là pleinement le choix qui
remettrait fille le sport c'est la rue
donc si on peut retrouver tout ce qui
est des terrains libres et pour l'heure
pas votre passion nous avons à dire ta
vie oeuvres donnent une image
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est un père dit d'un
ternie
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission il est 21h
heure française tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 27
avril un écoles transports distribution
de masques et de tests le gouvernement
peaufine sa stratégie de déconfinement
avant la présentation demain par edouard
philippe à l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre s'exprimera devant les
députés
dans la foulée un vote est prévu
l'opposition elle dénonce le manque de
temps de réflexion
à noter également que le nombre de
chômeurs bondy et de 7,1 pour cent en
mars une hausse record sur un mois aux
etats unis c est un témoignage qui
pourrait mettre dans l'embarras le
candidat démocrate à la maison blanche
en pleine campagne présidentielle
une femme accuse joe biden de l'avoir
agressée sexuellement en 1993 si
l'ancien président américain ne s'est
toujours pas exprimé son entourage lui
nie ces accusations
[Musique]
la france déplore plus de 23000 décès
liés aux coronavirus selon un nouveau
bilan donné par la direction générale de
la santé la hausse de ces dernières 24
heures et de 4 137 morts dont 295 les
hôpitaux depuis le début de l'épidémie
45 mille cinq cent treize personnes sont
entrées à domicile sans compter les
dizaines de milliers de personnes
guéries en ville
et alors que la situation sanitaire
globale s'améliore dans notre pays
l'exécutif doit donc dévoilé demain sa
stratégie nationale de déconfinement
edouard philippe présentera
officiellement son plan à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale
parmi les grands thèmes abordés la santé
l'école le travail les commerces les
transports et les rassemblements un vote
des députés est prévu à l'issue du débat
un délai de 24 heures a été demandée par
plusieurs membres de l'opposition mais
la conférence des présidents de
l'assemblée s'est prononcée contre un
report du vote à mercredi
plusieurs personnalités politiques ont
réagi regarder nous demandons une chose
c'est qu'il y ait un délai entre le
moment où le premier ministre présentera
ce plan est le moment où il ya le vote
nous demandons qu'il y ait un délai de
24 heures et que le vote soit mercredi
afin qu'on puisse avoir un débat
approfondi afin que les commissions
parlementaires puissent se réunir
c'est comme cela la démocratie ce n'est
pas un blanc-seing mais c'est simplement
un vote éclairé de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
je comprends cette demande à voir un
délai pour pouvoir regarder les mesures
du plan de déconfinement dans son
ensemble et se prononcer sur ces mesures
me semble de bon aloi
monsieur edouard philippe va arriver
mardi devant l'assemblée nationale va
nous réciter son discours nous dire
quelles seront les mesures
et ensuite séance tenante sans aucun
temps de réflexion d'eads examen
critique nous devront voter pour ou
contre
c'est une méthode insupportable je
demande à ce que le vote intervienne
quand nous aurons connaissance de
l'ensemble du plan de déconfinement
quand le gouvernement sera prêt alors
nous serons prêts à voter aussi en
connaissance de cause les conditions du
vote de mardi à la suite immédiate d'un
discours dont on ne sait rien sans une
loi nous permettant d'amender
sont un artifice du gouvernement pour
tenter de nous faire partager sa
responsabilité dans le fiasco de la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire
gouvernement et majorité refuse de vote
séparés sur applique au vide et
déconfinement et refusent aussi un délai
de 24 heures pour voter après avoir
entendu la déclaration du premier
ministre afin de pouvoir en débattre
entre députés
bref ça sent la fin de crise retour à la
surdité habituels tels pour en parler
justement nous sommes avec un jean
christophe lagarde président de l'udps
et y député de la 5e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis dont on vient de voir
la réaction sur twitter bonsoir jean
christophe lagarde merci d'être avec
nous vous fait donc partie de ceux qui
souhaitaient un délai à vous parler de
surdité de la part du gouvernement fin
de non recevoir de l'exécutif votre
réaction ce soir déçu oui déçu parce que
regarder le gouvernement qui nous a dit
il nous faut quinze jours que le
comprend pour pouvoir élaborer une
stratégie de confinement et le il
faudrait qu'on ait 15 minutes pour
décider si on trouve que c'est bien ou
pas alors que se pose des dizaines de
questions sur le retour alcool qu elle
soit maternelle qu'elle soit
élémentaires collèges ou lycées sur la
façon dont on peut pratiquer dans les
transports sur la façon dont on peut
travailler dans tel ou tel corps de
métier qui doit elle prioriser mais la
vente davantage encore sur la
territorialisation de déconfinement
aujourd'hui alors je parle la région
grand est la région ile-de-france qui
sont les deux régions les plus touchées
de france sont huit à neuf fois plus
touchés que la bretagne que la région
centre val de loire que la nouvelle à
qui tu es dedans on pourrait d'ores et
déjà d'ailleurs sans doute libéré une
partie du territoire français le virus
n'a quasiment pas circuler ou l'edb
l'état de d'urgence entre libère enfin
les services d'urgence dans les hôpitaux
sont en état de réagir s'il y avait un
problème alors que en ile-de-france dans
les autres france les personnels sont
épuisés laisse des médicaments
anesthésiants ne sont plus là les
équipements doivent être constituées en
cas de deuxième bague
donc il ya tellement de choses dont nous
devrions de berck donné 24 heures aux
députés pour pouvoir en débattre entre
eux parce qu'il faut observer une chose
demain nous serons 75 dans l'assemblée
nationale et il ya 577 députés
ça veut dire qu'il ya 500 de députés qui
ne seront pas là qu'ils ne peuvent pas
voter ou débattre et échanger entre eux
ont demandé 24 heures simplement pour
pouvoir en discuter entre nous comme les
français vont le faire comme le
gouvernement va le faire avec tout le
monde et c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment
que on est revenu à l'autoritarisme du
début du quinquennat d'avant les gilet
jaune
au lieu de construire ensemble ont fini
par vouloir de faire marcher au sein de
canon moi j'ai pas de souci à prendre
position et à accepter mes
responsabilités à condition que nous
puissions nous forger une idée dignement
et jean christophe lagarde tout de même
semaine pardonnez moi cette semaine de
confinement pour des français qui pour
certains commencent voilà à trouver le
temps long souhaite pour certains
retourner au travail on a vu le nombre
de chômeurs qui augmente vous le dites
vous-même ya tellement de sujets abordés
il ya un gouvernement qui a été élu
voilà pourquoi ne pas faire confiance ou
simplement au gouvernement pour prendre
les décisions je vous pose
volontairement la question d'abord il ya
de réponse à votre question la première
réponse c'est que si on décide et on l'a
fait en 48 heures l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du parlement ont donné il ya
six semaines les pleins pouvoirs au
gouvernement pour gérer la crise parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire à des lois la
vitesse où le virus se propage et six
semaines après si on a le sentiment est
un grand succès si on a le sentiment
qu'on nous a pas raconter des bobards
sur les masques que on a des problèmes
sur les tests qui sont toujours pas là
que finalement la france s'en sort mieux
que d'autres pays
quand on observe l'allemagne la suède où
d'autres alors en ce moment par la wii
on supprime le parlement et puis on n'a
qu'à dire que le gouvernement essaie
d'agir et la crise dans ces cas là
pourquoi un débat pourquoi vote
la réalité c'est que il fallait
co-construire ceci et je vais même vous
dire j'ai la conviction qu'il n'y aura
de succès dans le déconfinement problème
si c'est à dire qu'on arrive à reprendre
une vie à peu près normale
un peu modifié naturellement en compte
la circulation du virus qu'à une
condition qu'il y ait la confiance des
français
or les français n'ont pas confiance
parce qu'ils ont vu qu'on leur a raconté
des mensonges de les masquer et si le
gouvernement passe en force comme
malheureusement parfois la majorité nous
y habituer sans donner le temps de la
compréhension sans donner le temps de
mettre preuve de leur agression sans
donner le temps de la correction des
mesures qui seront données 24 heures
c'était pas grand chose
eh bien les français ne remettront pas
leurs enfants à l'école ils n'y vont pas
travailler
ils prendront pas le transport s'ils ont
le sentiment qu'on leur raconte à
nouveau des histoires et si ça ce qui me
rend malheureux c'est que le pro des
raisons de réflexes politiques on évite
d'arriver à construire ensemble ce que
ce dont nous avons besoin
moi je lis pas du tout et vous dites
avec confinement les gens en ont marre
mais moi aussi j'en ai marre tout le
monde en a marre on sait bien qu'il
faudra accorder confient les très
franchement le 11 mai ou le 30 septembre
on aura le même problème parce que le
virus continuera à circuler mais la
question c'est de prendre la discussion
la réflexion nécessaire qu'on ne
commettent pas d'erreurs
est ce qu'on est sûr que quand on nous a
dit il ya deux mois on ferme les écoles
d'abord parce que c'est là qu'il ya le
plus grand risque de propagation de
virus puisque les enfants peuvent le
porter le transmettre sans être malade
on le voit pas mais la première chose
qu'on est con vince et les écoles on est
sûr que ça marche
est ce qu'on pense franchement que les
écoles maternelles on va arriver où les
crèches arriver à faire respecter la
distanciation sociable les gestes
barrière or c'est vrai que c'est vrai
comme les médecins depuis son revenu un
petit peu sur les propos initiaux
concernant justement ces enfants super
propagateurs de virus peut être voilà
c'est un début d'explication
vous souhaitiez jean christophe lagarde
également un vote dissocier sur l'appli
qu'ovide et sur le déconfinement pour
quelles raisons c'était important pour
vous parce que ce sont deux sujets de
nature différente
l'abricot ville c'est un des éléments à
des outils dans la boîte à outils du
comment dirais-je du lait confinement et
de la stratégie de confinement la
question qui se pose est d'ailleurs il
ya quinze jours trois semaines quand on
a demandé à la fois seconde séparée et
que je souhaiterais mais que les
gouvernements là non plus n'acceptera
pas c'était est ce qu'il ya un problème
sur les libertés publiques moi je dis
aux français
après examen après audition de ministre
après avoir regardé ce qu'ils font y'a
pas de problème sur les libertés
publiques donc vous pourrez sans risque
téléchargez l'application quand elle
viendra bel small a en revanche synthé
jpy confinement pour parce qu'en fait la
bretagne à l'égal de services de
parapente plus elle ou ses paroles non
alors pourquoi on peut mettre tout le
monde sur la b3 alors que les situations
différentes
un technique on fait nos intelligences
et responsable progressif comme on le
dit c'est de s'adapter à trois choses 1
est ce que le virus a beaucoup circulé
dans la région ou dans les annales le
territoire en question
2 est ce qui reste des capacités de
soins notamment dans les services de
réanimation où est-ce qu'ils sont à bout
et il faut leur laisser le temps de
reconstituer leurs forces
3 est ce que les masques de protection
sont arrivés et dans les territoires et
ben non parce que le gouvernement nous a
dit il faut pas de masse
pourquoi parce qu'elle n'avait pas c'est
comme si les français n'avaient pas été
capables de comprendre n'auraient pas
été capables de comprendre que comme on
n'avait pas assez de masques mais il
fallait les réserver aux soignants parce
que si les soignants meubles personne
pour vous soigner
si on ne vais pas raconter des bobards
ya deux mois c'était plus simple
aujourd'hui de créer la confiance est là
il ya des collectivités locales qui à
cette époque l'état achète des masques
en soignant pas pour les français
contrairement séville président la
république et il ya les collectivités
locales qui achètent des masques
simplement faut le temps de les produire
le temps qu'ils arrivent donc je suis
convaincue qu' il ya des territoires qui
semble pourraient être des cons filet
dès demain parce que le virus il peut
circuler que leur état hospitalier est
en bonne situation de faire face et
parce qu'ils ont peut-être 38 les masses
et puis il ya des endroits où ça sera
pas possible on dit même qu'il fasse des
territoires et cette affaire hélas non
on décide d'en haut une date du 11 mai
d'hondt accessoirement le conseil
scientifique n'a jamais
dit qu'elle était bravo pas parce qu'il
n'a pas été consulté et on va donner on
fait partout la même chose
moi je crains que des compliments sont
un échec s'il n'ya pas confiance et si
on continue dans le nil invités merci à
vous jean christophe lagarde avoir été
en direct sur rt france et avec le
confinement les artisans se trouve dans
la tourmente ils sont nombreux à avoir
vu leur chiffre d'affaires dégringoler
estelle farges avec piotr sage hart
qu'ils se sont rendus dans le quartier
de belleville à paris où certains
d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs décidé de
mettre leur savoir faire au service des
autres une file d'attenté comme on en a
rarement vu devant l'atelier de ces
artisans du 19e arrondissement
tous ces gens patientent pour récupérer
un masque de protection en temps normal
dans cet atelier
florence et bérangère fabrique et
commercialise des gourdes éco
responsable mais depuis le 7 avril
dernier ce sont des masques qui tombent
de leur machine à coudre des masques
fabriqués à partir de dons de tissus
tout commence là donc à par exemple
c'est un tissu que qu'une personne du
voisinage nous a donné ça s'appelle
awacs c'est du 100% coton que nous avons
lavés à 60 degrés on l'a repassé et
après j'ai un patron que j'ai me condat
à préparer donc ça c'est pour petite
taille pour les enfants et ça c'est pour
les adultes
on les coupe comme ça voilà donc à
quelques étapes au passage et cetera
pour aboutir à ça
ça c'est un car et c'est là découperez
j'ai fait avec les plis
voilà donc double tissu et une fois que
cette assemblée
on arrive à ce modèle qui est là une
petite révolution pour les deux artisans
qui s'est imposé comme une évidence
il faut savoir qu'on la vit dans un
quartier populaire des gens l ont pas
beaucoup de fous il manque d'information
etc
donc on essaye de les aider c'est pas
eux qui vont aller acheter des masques à
30 euros ou je ne sais où
sur le net on doit l'admettre ça fait
partie de notre vie que d'aider son
prochain au mieux qu'on peut en tout
elles sont sept à venir ici bénévolement
16h30 les grilles s'ouvrent un par un
les gens rentrent et s'est mis à 17 ans
la fille de florence qui assure la
distribution
une centaine de masques distribués ici
tous les jours les gens donnent en
moyenne 3 euros pour un masque de quoi
permettre aux deux femmes d'acheter les
cordons qui serviront à leur conception
ou encore de payer l'électricité de
leurs ateliers
mais pour le reste et notamment l'avenir
de leur entreprise
c'est un gros point d'interrogation
c'est vrai qu'avec le coc vide toutes
nos commandes toutes nos commandes alors
qu'on avait travaillées dieu pour se
relever de la crise les jaunes ont été
annulés c'est le plus de la moitié du
chiffre d'affaires de l'année qui
disparaît donc effectivement les reports
de loyer ce sera pas suffisant sinon
nous allume sur n'annule pas les
factures
ça suffira pas à nous sortir de là
bérengère florence et toutes ces petites
mains bienveillantes vont continuer de
coudre des masques ici six jours sur
sept jusqu'à nouvel ordre
en attendant de savoir de quoi l'avenir
sera fait
mais on part à présent outre atlantique
sur le continent américain le mexique a
lancé une gigantesque production de
masques de protection
lépine dizaine de jours son port est
obligatoire dans les transports publics
de nombreux états du pays lustration à
mexico avec le cas tu allais au mattei
rémy morano mexico une agglomération de
plus de 20 millions d'habitants
face à l'épidémie de coronavirus dans le
pays
difficile d'imposer un confinement total
plus de la moitié de la population
active survie au jour le jour
impossible pour elle de ne pas aller
travailler si les déplacements sont
possibles les autorités ont en revanche
rendu le port du masque obligatoire dans
les transports publics à l'entrée des
stations
ils sont distribués gratuitement merci
beaucoup
enfilez le s'il vous plaît
le métro de mexico un réseau immense où
se croisent plus de quatre millions et
demi de passagers par jour
une promiscuité qui multiplie les
risques de contamination on a des
paquets de 200-300 masque chacun quand
on en finit 1
on communique immédiatement par
téléphone pour en avoir à nouveau
quand on voit que le virus s'est répandu
de l'asie à l'europe avant d'arriver ici
je suis vraiment surpris que dans
beaucoup de ces pays on n'est pas encore
pris des mesures comme celle ci
je le mets tous les jours depuis le
moment où je sors de chez moi au travail
pareil retour je fais attention à ne
jamais lui enlever par précaution et
pour la sécurité des autres j'en utilise
chaque jour plusieurs différends quand
j'arrive au travail j'enlève celui ci je
le change est pareil quand je sors
si les masques chirurgicaux sont
distribués dans le métro et certains
préfèrent en acheter de plus performant
dans les pharmacies c'est le cas de
mathilde une musicienne française
installée au mexique depuis trois ans
ici aucune pénurie de masques
le mexique a tout misé sur une
production nationale importante le pays
en fabrique suffisamment pour répondre
aux besoins de sa population et même
pour en exporter à l'étranger une
situation bien loin de celle de la
france et mathilde en est consciente
quand j'appelle mes amis et en france
ils ont pas de masque en fait donc je
leur demande s'ils mettent des masques
way
non non pas du tout et c'est vrai que ça
les étonne que nous ici au mexique la
plupart des gens mais en milieu de
semaine le mexique a dépassé la barre
des 1000 décès un bilan important mais
bien loin de celui de son voisin du nord
les états unis avec pas loin de 55 mille
morts et près d'un million d'infection
confirmés les états unis restent le
principal foyer de la pandémie ville la
plus touchée et new york avec un point
de 17000 des ces signes d'espoir les
hospitalisations en baisser le nombre de
décès a chuté en 24 heures 3 167 morts
le plus faible bilan quotidien depuis le
30 mars le gouverneur de l'état donc
annoncé le possible redémarrage de
certaines activités maintenues
effectuèrent et de construction à partir
du 15 mai la pause dans tout l'état et
jusqu'au 15 mai ensuite les directives
du cdc stipule que le nombre total de
spécialisation doit être en baisse
pendant 14 jours
la première phase de la réouverture
concernera les activités construction et
de fabrication weeks nous allons alors
laissé deux semaines entre les phases
pour pouvoir contrôler les fêtes de ce
que nous avons fait agir survie les
lectures aux etats unis outre cette
crise du corona mieux c'est aussi la
campagne présidentielle de joe biden qui
se complique à sept mois des élections
le candidat démocrate est à présent
accusé d'agression sexuelle archives
d'un témoignage anonyme à la télévision
américaine pourrait plonger l'ancien
vice président dans l'embarras les
détails en images
tous
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'un employé parlementaire
peut faire à part parler à la presse ma
fille vient de quitter washington après
avoir travaillé pour un sénateur
important elle n'a pas pu surmonter son
problème
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurent cesari professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras
bonsoir laurent cesari merci d'être avec
nous et effectivement on en parle peu en
pleine crise du coronavirus mais il ya
quand même cette campagne présidentielle
avec joe biden
du côté des démocrates pourquoi ce
témoignage de 1993 ressort-il maintenant
ça fait loin qu'en mai 1993 il nous
ressort
ça fait quelques semaines déjà qu'on en
parle et où pour l'un c'est que je pense
que s'il ressort aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'à un élément supplémentaire qui est
là la déclaration de la mère de la
victime supposée que l'on a trouvé au
jour puisque le deuxième de simples à la
ville a publié aujourd'hui s'il est
certain que ça vient à un mauvais moment
parce que ça vient un moment où il est
comment dire les difficultés qu'elle est
rom dans ses conférences de presse ces
derniers temps
by dell est la situation semblait
remonter courbe hayden cela dit moi
j'attends un petit peu de voir parce que
si effectivement ça fait 1-1 scandale
sexuel du côté de baden trump n'est pas
tout blanc de ce côté là non plus si
j'ose dire
alors pour bien qu'on comprenne de quels
éléments dispose cette femme aujourd'hui
coûté pour l'instant inscrit que ce qui
ressortit c'est le sait le témoignage
donc de la mer de la delà de la victime
que de set à fédérer cette émission de
1993 pour l'instant ça reste
j'ai dû non prouvées enfin on va bien
voir ce qui va se passer
alors là la faire vous l'avez dit date
de ne peuvent en quelques semaines à
peine s quelquefois influence peut poser
influer sur la campagne a sans doute
c'est difficile de dire jusqu'à quel
point parce qu'à mon avis on a quand
même à faire à deux candidats faible
aussi bien byden que trump eux contre
les câliner pas difficile de trouver des
griefs et celui ci du côté de pas et de
plus c'est difficile de jeu bordelais
c'est difficile de jeu sera un élément
déterminant alors le candidat ado boys
and lui ne s'est pas encore exprimé
c'est une parole qui est très attendu on
sait juste que son entourage nie
farouchement pour l'instant on attend la
parole de joe biden à ce qu'elle est non
parce que déjà audible on sait qu trice
du corps aux navires us - byden il n'a
pas grand chose à faire en ce moment il
tout le monde disait au moment de
l'abandon de deux sondeurs ce que tu
rebelles être réélu d'en face en
difficulté moi j'en suis un petit peu un
petit peu moins sûr parce que de le
parti démocrate
gounon ma lancée réunis autour de baden
enfin la gauche du parti a bien compris
que si elle voulait pas donner la
direction
il faudrait bien que le quel vous dire
qu'elle serait là qu'elle accepte by
then ces quelques occasions cortese par
exemple les publications de gauche aux
états unis mais min 7 la semaine
dernière qu'on a mentionné à l'instant
était plus sur une ligne de négociation
que de refus de principe contre contre
maidan en dix ans dans la mesure où son
programme évoluera vers la gauche
notre soutien comment dire ça scintille
et s'intensifiera ou non
en conséquence la évidemment et c'est
quelque chose qui veut rendre la chose
plus difficile c'est certain
cela dit trump monde lui aussi quand
même on se souvient de ses déclarations
sur les femmes lors de sa je parle à sa
campagne à quatre ans qui est quelque
peu reluisante
il est rom ce moment comme les
manifestants un peu dépassé par la la la
gestion de la crise du du cv 19
il fait un petit peu peur à ce qu'est la
passe de son électorat à savoir les
blancs jeu donc je pense que pour les
shows pour l'instant les choses sont
très ouvertes
merci affaire à suivre donc merci
laurence et harry professeur d'histoire
contemporaine est d'avoir été avec nous
et c'est la fin de cette émission vous
le savez un peu capoté en ces temps de
coronavirus comme tous les autres médias
nous nous adaptons en attendant les
programmes continus sur air france
prochain point sur l'actualité ce sera
demain matin à 8 heures excellente fin
de soirée à tous
[Musique]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dit et
le redit cela le problème c'est que dans
le cas du confinement il n'y a plus cet
entourage et tout se fait à distance ce
qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude elles
portent plutôt sur ce que nous voyons
pas la partie immergée de l'iceberg en
fait parce que les très difficile pour
les enfants malgré tout d'aller le même
et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
tchèque où politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême musée
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview ici on écoute
ceux qui ne sont pas